uh i saw your auntie was in here
she's an integral part of your career
yeah how important is it to keep
everything close in the family man i
mean it's
i don't know you got to keep them close
because it's a lot of people like i just
she was there the whole time i was in
jail so that's why i always got her
around
but i don't know it's a lot yeah
it's a lot of stuff you're going on you
got to keep people you trust around
because
i didn't have people steal money from me
all type of [ __ ] when i was in jail so
people were stealing from me while you
were in jail what
sure and what like in what capacity
because like like
like you know you're locked up you have
you got i'm assuming there's some
liquidity somewhere yeah people i'm
letting people you know
people who you trusted people i'm
trusted use my car
pull out money handle things for me oh
they was pulling out money out of your
cards
yeah pulling out [ __ ] so you get out of
jail you
then you you're like expecting you got a
certain amount of money in the bank
yeah that too but i had two i had like a
business account or another one so i was
expecting to
get some money from the whole man oh
yeah go put this out for me hey
damn bro for real twenty thousand
dollars huh
so 20 bags is missing yeah luckily i'm a
different person now
yeah that's a lot of money that's a lot
of money but the eyes are on you right
now
you might want to you know it might be
it might be a twenty thousand dollars
worth taking bro
i'm changed safe to say those people
aren't around anymore no they're not
damn i can only imagine bro hey exactly
right